six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty is the number let's try the
nine seven zero area code caller from
nine seven zero go ahead hi it's Jackson
from Colorado and so my question my
question is so I'm going to college
overseas in Ireland this fall and since
you have family in Argentina I was kind
of wondering like how do you explain the
Donald Trump phenomenon to someone that
might be used to like a more progressive
political system okay so I deal with
this a lot I go to Argentina when so
there's very few black people in
Argentina so when President Obama was
president I'd go to Argentina and people
would say David what's it like having a
black president and I would have no
problem answering that when I would say
it's the same as having a white
president you really evaluate them on
policy now though people are saying what
is happening in the United States what
happened with Donald Trump people must
love him and what I find to be the most
effective thing to explain right away
especially when you're talking to people
from European countries European
countries are much smaller than the
United States and they still can have
pretty big differences from one region
to another so first thing is explain how
big the United States is how many people
live in the United States and make it
clear that the United States really
could be different countries and if you
look at a country like Switzerland which
has a French German and Italian region
and you look at in such a small
geographical area how significant the
differences are culturally between some
of those regions look at the United
States which is orders of magnitude
bigger and the differences between
Northeast culture and Appalachia and the
big you know the Mountain States and so
on it's so different that you can't
really make a broad judgement about
what's going on in Boston and New York
and DC because 65% of Utah decided to
vote for Donald Trump I think that that
is one of the most useful things to
explain to particularly Europeans about
what's happening with Trump in the
United States I think that's a really
good way to look at it and also I
like there there's lots of differences
between like different groups in like
within the states I mean like I like in
California when people think in San
Francisco is going to be very different
but but like from what people believe in
rural parts of the valley absolutely and
you have you know on education on a
cultural sensitivity on religion like
you have what are undeniably just
massive rifts between American
populations and the people that support
Trump could not be more different from
the people that oppose Trump in many
ways and in many cases you know a Boston
business bro that supports Trump is not
going to be as different from me as you
know a rural northern Indiana farmer is
going to be from me so it's not like
everybody right that nobody has anything
in common but there's some pretty major
majorly different cultural issues going
on good luck in Nollan that sounds
pretty interesting
thank you all right appreciate the call
I'm pleased to tell you that today's
show is underwritten by better help.com
slash Pakman therapy is important we
have a real crisis in our country not
just people who could benefit from
mental health services but the stigma
that surrounds mental health services
and as many people in the audience know
lots of people in my family work in the
field of mental health and I have made
it a mission of the show to at any
opportunity make clear that there is
absolutely no shame whatsoever in going
to talk to someone when you feel that
that's the right thing to do and that's
what better help provides you get a
fully licensed and experienced
psychologists and therapists through
video phone and text it's less expensive
than meeting in person with a counselor
after three months the price goes down
even more but you get the same
professional service that you would from
going into somebody's office and you
also get unlimited access you can speak
to a counselor every day if you want
signing up is easy you go to better help
calm slash Pakman fill out a
questionnaire they will pair you with a
therapist that works for you but you're
always
able to switch to somebody else if
there's a better fit available go to
better help calm slash Pakman it's so
easy to sign up and get started we're
putting a link in the description if
you're watching this on YouTube it is
better help calm a slash PA que ma n